voilà c'est dit marie est une femme très
amoureux et qui s'entendent très bien et
donc la femme est un soir lui dit tu
sais chérie on s'aime énormément mais si
je n'ai à mourir le promets moi une
chose je veux que tu me remplace parce
que tu es un mec formidable et il faut
pas que tu restes seul je voudrais
vraiment que tu me remplace enchérit moi
je serai très triste mais bien sûr je
oui bah tu me promets que tu me
remplacera tu feras venir cette femme
dans notre maison
oui oui oui mais enfin ne me parle pas
de ça là tout va bien tu es en forme etc
non non non mais elle viendrait dans
notre maison la cuisine raie au milieu
de mes ustensiles elle serait promets
moi que tu le feras premiers mois oui
est-ce qu'elle mettra aussi mes
vêtements tu peux tu peux tu sais alors
il lui dit oui oui bon mais c'est dur ce
que tu m'amènes latuner m'aidera dans
notre lit aussi un tu me promet alors là
il fait oui oui et tu la laissera aussi
utiliser mon club de golf et la lui a
dit à brad aurait elle est gauchère
ouais c'est une femme en fait elle est
divorcée elle a deux enfants elle vit
tout seul et elle doit 2000 euros de
loyer si nom de son propriétaire il va
là il va labazée et donc elle n'en peut
plus elle a même pas d'argent les
vraiment à la rue et donc elle fait une
lettre au bon dieu un soir alan peu plus
dans sa chambre comme ça fait mon dieu
s'il vous plaît aidez moi j'ai besoin de
2000 euros pour payer mon loyer sinon je
vais me faire envoyer aimé ça dans l'
enveloppe et elle a tellement pas
d'argent que elle a même pas d'argent
pour payer le temple et et mail adresse
derrière son enveloppe et avant elle
envoie sa la poste
les postiers comme ça et des charges
c'est au jo quoi tu as vu la lettre est
marquée pour le ciel adresse le ciel
bourdieu adresse le ciel c'est quoi
cette lettre vas-y jette la viande
louvre mais non ça fait pas de façon
elle est morte planète n'est même pas de
tomber en louvre d'accord et élise la
lettre de la femme
voilà il me faut deux mille euros sinon
je vais me faire envoyer tout ça bon les
possibles faisais tu sais quoi j'ai une
idée moi on va cotiser on va leur
envoyer d'argent
ouah bonne idée officiel adresse
derrière loeb ok pas de problème
il lui on voit l'argent mais ils
n'arrivent pas à cotiser 2000 euros il
arriva a récolté que 1800 euros moi
c'est pas grave il envoie sa la poste la
famille rentrent chez elles et tout ça
elles sont utilisées son petit courrier
et voix veuillez trouver ci-joint pour
votre loyer 1800 euros
wade comme une folle et le crime et
c'est magnifique je corresponds avec
dieu c'est magnifique
elle rentre chez elle et elle refait une
petite liste voilà j'ai besoin de çà çà
çà çà çà çà çà électroménager téléphones
plein de choses et tout ça va demander
dans des effets ps s'il vous plaît mon
dieu
la prochaine fois vous me donner les
réponses ne m'en veuillez pas par la
poste parce que je crois que là bas ils
m'ont pris 200 euros
c'est un arabe en français et américains
qui sont étaient chez un riche
milliardaire faire un riche milliardaire
il sait plus quoi faire de son argent il
décide de se faire un petit kiff il
invite en arabe en français 1 américain
au bord de sa piscine une piscine
remplie de crocodiles il les regarde
tous les trois ils heures d'écouté et
j'ai un défi pour vous vous avez sauté
dans la piscine
celui qui ne meurent pas à le droit de
me demander ce qu'il veut ils disent ok
c'est parti le français il saute dans la
piscine se bouffer par les crocodiles
c'est terminé l'américain eli va il
saute dans la piscine is fait bouffer
par les crocodiles
d'un coup on voit l'arabe qui remonte
comme ça sur le côté romand qui lui
manque un bras une jambe
le milliardaire et le regard comme c'est
de l'apologie dior bravo bravo alors
qu'est ce que tu veux il y trouve moi
l'enculé qui m'a poussé d'abord je
remercie kelly vdo vie qui m'a beaucoup
aidé pour préparer mes blagues c'est
celle de blague
les soldats sont blessés alors c'est un
missionnaire blanc qui va dans une tribu
africaine
ouais et puis le temps passe il adopté
par la tribu enfin tout va bien bas et
puis on ya un bébé blanc qui n'est alors
tout on se pose des questions parce
qu'ils anaya qu'un blanc à qui vit avec
eux et et un jour le chemin de vie lâche
le convoque et luigi
écoute moi le bébé blanc c'est toi on
est d'accord dans le meck emmerder et
c'est parce que sinon ils vont avoir
l'envoyer ils vont le tuer ou quoi parce
que il n'a pas le droit de faire ça et
du coup il dit mais non on regarde
regarde tu vois bien les chèvres il ya
un troupeau blanc il y en a une noire je
suis dit bon écoute je dis pas pour le
bébé tu dis pas pour les chèvres
[Applaudissements]
je ne l'espère aussi la tête est nouveau
il arrivait d'un pleine forme elle
arrive comme ça
et hop directs d'état moyer à la
synagogue de paris pour faire un
contrôle fiscal d'énergie dans la
synagogue comme ça hop l'on avait la
rive tranquille et le calme de l'autre
il est plein de questions ça et lui dit
alors sur leurs abeilles voilà été là je
vois et dire et tout ses bougies là et
tout après le phone d'abandonner aider
tout cette cire alors qu'est ce que vous
en faites pas on récupère la c1
on envoie notre fournisseur et notre
fournisseur une fois par an et nous
renvoie un paquet de bougies gratuit
et j le pen azim tous à tous nos
paisibles que vous avez toutes les
miettes et tout qu'est-ce que vous en
fait de toutes ces miettes à djabla là
c'est pareil
j'ai une fois par an on le renvoie notre
boulanger et nous renvoie du pain
gratuit et 10 et bien vous allez
répondre à toutes les questions c'est
bien mais des cahiers les circoncisions
à tous ces petits bouts de peau tout ça
et c'est là que vous en faites
il disait pareil une fois par an les
hameaux impôts et nous rend moins glam
[Rires]
by side trois mecs de la sécurité qui
rentre dans une piscine ils prennent un
mec il le jette de la piscine et le
directeur de la piscine qui vient voir
le mec je dis c'est la dernière fois que
vous vainquions curieux que vous revenez
dans ces piscines qui dois je suis pas
le seul à pisser dans l'eau mais qui dit
du plongeoir si ces vieux qui t'y vas
voir son copain médecins etc ou 3g je
vais nous gênions occasions mais en
angers genres entre une petite équipe
oeuvres sur un caramel un caramel
c'est mon chant du cygne donne moi ta
petite pilule bleue
non vous allez avoir une attaque s'il te
plaît à poste ne peux rien je veux finir
en beauté maire donne moi de cette
typique bon goût c'est le renommé soir
elles ont affronté la une une seule où
mes paroles paroles
toujours à paris alors alors je te
remercie tu peux pas savoir jean des
prix c'était moins doit y en avait
partout papa d'être content de ce titre
elle est pas venu
c'est à c'est un juif qui a un contrôle
fiscal
l'inspecteur des impôts a dit monsieur
cohen vous ne prendriez pas pour un con
par hasard j pourquoi ai dit vous
déclarez toujours 1800 euros brut par
mois et dit oui il y alors vous pouvez
m'expliquer votre résidence à deauville
la maison à saint tropez
le pavillon de saint mandé idjwi il joue
bien sûr ça c'est facile il jean nuit je
dors chez ma mère à sarcelles ils disent
fait un rêve dans la nuit copier de son
jardin au pied de l'arbre vient trésor
le lendemain matin il dit j'ai été
creusés j'ai trouvé un trésor
edit ah oui et vous avez la preuve de
sai dit oui la résidence à deauville
mais au moins ça
[Applaudissements]